[Music]
it's may and news outlets are still
reporting news stories of people being
arrested for participating in the
january 6th
attack on the capitol and law
enforcement has had some help
in the form of one of my favorite
investigative bodies
america's ex-girlfriends catfishes and
bumble [ __ ]
that's right women have been turning in
their exes
and catfishing and screenshotting men
who have bragged on dating apps and
social media
about their role in the january 6th
riots white
women using their super power of
tattling for good
you love to see it but as tickled as i
am about this sisters are doing it for
themselves approach to counterterrorism
i have to ask how did we end up with
this many people
feeling so comfortable committing an act
of terrorism in broad daylight and then
bragging about it let's find out in a
segment called
how did we get here
the largest organized group at the
capitol riot on january 6th was a group
called the proud boys which
sounds like a brand of underpants for
boys who have just been potty trained
but it's not it's actually the name of a
large white supremacist movement
in fact it's one of many white
supremacist groups who participated in
the riots that day
these groups organized the january 6th
attack
openly online and two of their leaders
were these two guys
joseph biggs and ethan nordin biggs and
nordine have both been
really lucky when it comes to not
getting arrested for crimes they
committed
right in front of police in 2016 biggs
beat up a protester at the republican
national convention
but police only charged the man he beat
up
not biggs does that sound suspicious it
should
because the police actually ended up
settling a civil case for falsifying
their own documents
to make them more sympathetic to biggs
but of course they were sympathetic to
biggs
what would the police look like
arresting him for beating up a protester
it's literally their favorite thing to
do
biggs's friend nordim also punched a
protester
in oregon the man he punched was
arrested and
nor dean wasn't the whole thing was
caught on video and the proud boys
successfully used
that video as a recruiting tool online
these two prolific punchers brought a
hundred of their closest friends to dc
on january 6th to storm the capital
thinking
for good reason they could get away with
it it would be like if every time you
shoplifted you got a little kiss on the
forehead
you'd think i can't wait to shoplift
some more
many right-wing extremist groups
participated that day they planned the
whole thing openly online
and they posted videos of themselves
storming the capital
so why did they get the idea this was an
acceptable thing to do
it's simple because the federal
government stopped tracking domestic
terrorism a decade ago and
that has allowed white supremacist
domestic terrorist
groups to flourish unchecked now i know
that sounds like a liberal rumor like
j-lo and ben getting back together but
it's actually a fact
like j-lo and puffy getting back
together so
how did we get the fair i'm so glad you
asked
in 1995 timothy mcveigh carried out the
oklahoma city bombing
the deadliest domestic terrorist attack
in u.s history
after that the feds cracked down on
domestic terrorism and it worked
in the 1990s the number of domestic
terrorist attacks
diminished if only they could have done
a similar crackdown
on frosted tips two
cuties anyway it stayed that way until
2009 when
right-wing domestic terrorism started to
go up again
can you guess why honestly if you've
been watching the show
you should be able to guess why
that's right we elected a black
president
white people lost their whole dang minds
and white supremacist
groups suddenly saw an uptick in
membership
in 2009 the department of homeland
security produced a report
warning about the rise in right-wing
domestic terrorism
now i've never understood why whenever
people are talking about white
supremacists
republicans insist on raising their
hands and going
they're talking about us talk about
telling on yourself
sweetie nobody said your name but you
anyway
fox news and republicans made a huge
stink about how an attack on domestic
terrorists
was actually an attack on them and then
something crazy happened
the obama administration caved to them
they buried the report and
disbanded the unit that tracked right
wing domestic terrorists
obama baby i love you but you really
oh what's that oh he can't hear me
because he's recording a podcast with
bruce springsteen
good for him ever since then the number
of right-wing terrorist attacks has
grown
peaking in 2020 why 2020 because
at this point not only was trump fanning
the flames of white nationalism
on camera he also started helping them
out behind the scenes
that's right you know it's not a story
about something bad happening in america
unless trump shows up to make it worse
in 2020 trump's campaign message was
that the left was a threat to
america so he ordered the justice
department to find
some left-wing terrorists federal agents
were shifted away from right-wing
targets and pressured to uncover a
left-wing
extremist conspiracy that did not exist
of course it didn't you think the left
is capable of pulling off a conspiracy
we can barely pull off an election
trump's department of homeland security
denied requests for funding to search
for warnings of extremism online
pretty embarrassing choice considering a
bunch of extremists tried to overthrow
the government and they planned it
online
they couldn't spot it but i did and i'm
just a lady with a twitter account and
spotty spectrum wi-fi
and that's how we got here law
enforcement ignored the individual
threats
right in front of their faces missed the
last decade of a rising trend simply
because republicans told them to and
then
they literally looked the other way
while criminals walked past them in
broad daylight
like every police cat in every cartoon
about a criminal mouse
and that's how we got here with our best
tool against domestic terrorism being
america's brave ex-girlfriends
well thank you for your service ladies
keep up the good work
because nobody else is doing it this has
been how do we get here
[Music]
you